for more on all of this let's go to
chief washington correspondent major
garrity joins us now major good morning
i think it's important to point out that
the only reason we are talking about
this today that we know about it at all
is because donald trump himself issued a
statement on it
that has context how significant is this
fbi search of the former president's
home it doesn't get any more significant
than this not only is former president
trump someone who looms large in
america's political conversation he is
actively talking about seeking the
presidency again
so this would be
something the justice department would
have to review at the highest levels as
was said in catherine's piece and a
grand jury and a judge would have to say
there is probable cause to execute a
search warrant because that search
warrant is in pursuit of a possible
crime having been committed all of that
is true but what we don't have is very
much transparency from the justice
department or the fbi we have one
statement from the former president
using very fluid language my home is
under siege raided occupied essentially
a search warrant was executed because
the judicial authorities with all the
relevant facts believe there's probable
cause that a crime was committed but in
the larger political context this is a
dangerous and unstable moment in
american history
this is now a conversation about
weaponizing the justice system at the
federal level and trump supporters hear
that and they may react in a very
combustible way
well that that's where i was going to go
with this follow-up question here uh
major christopher wray the fbi director
who presumably had to sign off on a raid
of this significance is a trump
appointee after the former president
famously fired the last fbi director and
also the fbi is supposed to be a
non-partisan agency of law enforcement
uh it's doing its work on ten-year terms
at the director level so what talk a bit
more about the implications of the
former president using those explosive
words to describe this important arm of
the government well it's not only the
president's words so many other
republicans almost instantaneously as if
former president trump was a ringmaster
directing them rhetorically into this
battle described this as
a prime example of judicial corruption
they described the biden administration
as a regime they basically said that the
fbi should be defunded some republicans
did rushing to the defense of former
president trump assuming that this has
to be a nefarious and illegitimate and
corrupt exercise of law enforcement
prerogatives when it may be quite the
opposite we don't know what the
underlying facts are we haven't seen the
affidavit we haven't seen the search
warrant and as i understand it because
of this sensitivity there would be a
conversation between former president
trump's lawyers on the scene about what
was taken and why and a receipt given to
the former president describing what
federal authorities took and under what
legal authorities the president the
former president is in possession of
that and could help explain to the
public what happened he could release
that if he wanted to so could the
justice department so could the fbi what
we lack here is real insight into the
underlying justification for this search
warrant what it sought and what the
applicable laws that possibly were
violated were until we know more about
that this feels deeply politicized and
the president is reveling in the
atmosphere of victimhood as he has many
times before
you know major i hear the critics of the
president saying listen there better be
a real there there or at least this
could further divide the country his
supporters say look once again it's a
it's a witch hunt against the president
you know even using the word
unprecedented depending on your point of
view unprecedented because this has
never happened before witch hunt for
president trump unprecedented if you're
against the president because you think
well surely they have something how do
you square those two
so
we hear this said all the time gail the
rule of law in our country matters and
no one is above the law merrick garland
the attorney general has said that
repeatedly he said it very emphatically
to our colleague jeff begays who asked
him that question specifically
referencing former president trump about
possible prosecution so the country has
this moment where it has to evaluate
underlying evidence and what the
evidence is and what the possible crimes
are and without that you have a very
political atmosphere one in which the
former president
currently has the upper hand
all right major garrett so much to
unpack here thank you so much